like a few months ago wow yeah and
that's blowing up it's doing well it's
doing really well yeah wow yeah i might
have them and you're making good money
yeah yeah cause it's not the car you
rolled up in yeah yeah nice
durango cat yeah and you got a girl yes
wow i do how did you meet her internet
no i met her through my sister
that's how you do it huh because i was
like yo i keep meeting
[ __ ] like
someone who's like
only knows my music or you know what i
mean like sneaky like fan [ __ ] yeah like
like do you like me for who i am you can
like me for what i keep saying sneaky
there's these i know so basically
basically he's i'm single now
he's worried that women are sneaky not
all women yeah but but jesus christ yeah
but you know but in general the women
that want to hang out with me he's
saying are sneaky what are their motives
they know a lot about i'm being very
protective of the world right now yeah
yeah so i there's some sneaky vibes and
i don't like the sneaky vibe yeah
you know like meeting if you could meet
someone through a mutual friend like how
he met his girl i feel like that's like
the best yeah see i don't go to bars
like even like i get anxiety and like
places like that yeah like i have social
anxiety for sure ptsd or some [ __ ] and
so for me like
hanging out at a friend's house or the
studio or the movies like that [ __ ]
where i'm comfortable i'm going out to
bars and [ __ ] so i'm like i'm not going
to meet anyone normal ever you know what
i mean right
so then so you but you met it through
your friends your sister's friend yeah
i'm like one of your friends has to
think i'm hot you know
you start saying that to all your
friends yeah yeah yeah
i mean what are the odds
but what are the odds of you saying it
to a friend and then yeah i know lucy
she hasn't dated anyone 30 years
i mean she can't be hot she pulls out
like hell by
yeah yeah i mean when you first saw your
sister's friend well i had met her
before so you knew she yeah yeah and i
was like okay
yeah yeah yeah okay i think i felt the
connection there you know oh i see yeah
and did it happen right away or it was
pretty like instant right when we met
her we kind of like
knew
there was a vibe you know right yeah and
how long you've been dating her
uh almost a year now congratulations
thank you awesome your love i am in love
let's go let's go dawg
let's talk about this
the vaping
the vape i was off of this [ __ ]
until i [ __ ] met you [ __ ]
you vape way too much
it's a problem yeah
do you think this is too much do you
think this is killing you i was about to
say the vaping that's leading us to our
death
i think these these these topics can go
hand in hand all right you know
so my goal was like